so I'm all about the youth generation I
focused much more in the latter part
than the the other piece I have to
address key issues of course I do that's
part of my job as a US diplomat however
are you kidding me I'm talent scouting
around the world I'm building networks
of like-minded thinkers I am all over
this I am all over generation change I
am optimistic about the future of what's
happening because I meet these amazing
people around the world people keep
telling me I have the world worst job I
can't believe you have to go and talk
about these serious issues and I'm like
have you met the underage 30 crowd
around the world because they're pretty
amazing and I have so much faith in what
you guys can do i do and i don't care if
you're Muslim or you're not Muslim you
can move these ideas forward about
pluralism about interfaith about
connectivity it is your generation that
can teach our generation how to do this
better and that's what I'm all about so
that's what I'm focusing about